Ladies and Gentlemen,
Dr Jordan Peterson.
Thank you.
Norwegian say knowing further,
extroverted enthusiasm.
That's pretty sweet.
Coming out to that,
huh?
Yeah,
yeah,
that's for sure.
Alright,
so here's what we're going to do.
I want to go through some of the big
questions that I've come up with during
the last five or six months on the road
with you,
which you've just been an incredible,
truly life changing time for me.
Uh,
and then we're going to end with Oslo as
best question.
You've got 45 minutes and you will see.
All right,
so first off,
every single night you are different and
I think tonight perhaps different,
more different than any night so far.
How the hell do you do it?
I honestly don't know.
I,
you know,
I usually go back in the green room with
you for a little bit before and about 10
minutes,
10 minutes before showtime.
I walk out of there and you say you need
to think for a little bit and then you
somehow do an hour and a half summing up
everything you think in a different way
on any given night.
Well,
there's some Atlanta that technically,
you know,
the first thing is,
is that something I tell my students,
you know,
if,
if you want to write an essay,
you need a problem because the essay is
an attempt to solve a problem.
So first of all you need a problem and
then second,
if you're going to devote time to the
problem,
then it should be like,
it should be a problem.
That is your problem.
At least a piece of it should be,
you know,
I have students all the time and they
come up to me and they say,
tell me what I should write my essay
about.
And they're often very annoyed that I
haven't,
you know,
you didn't give us a topic.
It's like,
yes,
that's because the topic is the
difficult part of the assignment,
right?
To specify the problem.
That's the difficult part of the
assignment.
In fact,
when you're trying to,
when you're trying to address a complex,
let's say domain of suffering,
the diagnosis,
which is the problem formulation is the
crucial cognitive step.
So if you want to write,
you need a problem and and if you want
to write truthfully then you need a
problem that's yours and if you want to
write in a focused and aimed manner then
you unite your thinking around the
problem.
And so one thing I always do before when
I sit backstage is I think,
okay,
what's the problem for tonight?
You know,
and the problem for tonight was victim.
So it's one statements like,
okay,
let's explore the concept of victim and
go down as far as we possibly can.
Okay.
So then,
well then I would say my,
I have my knowledge organized in a
idiosyncratic manner and that's a
consequence of having spent.
When I wrote,
wrote my first book,
which was maps of meaning,
I wrote every day for three hours for 15
years and I vowed when I started that I
was going to make that.
What would you say that the highest duty
that I had,
nothing was going to come before that.
And there's a certain amount of cruelty
in that because it meant that,
you know,
if my wife came into my office than I
would bark at her and if my kids came
into my office like a junkyard dogs
surrounded by barbed wire,
it's like because you can always not,
right?
It's not that important that day and
there might be more pressing concerns
and they're probably including people
who would just like to have something to
do with you for awhile or do something
nicer,
have a problem fixed.
It's like,
no,
go away.
I've got three hours.
And so I see I,
I,
I was a thief and I took that from my
life.
And so I spent a very long time writing
and thinking about the hardest problem
that I could conceptualize.
And that was the relationship between
the individual and the atrocity
committed in the service of totalitarian
possession.
It was the worst problem I could think
of.
How so?
I look to see what the worst thing
people could do under the worst
circumstances was and tried to figure
out why that happened.
That was step one and step two was
having come to some determination about
how it might happen then and having
learned something that I had suspected
all along,
which was that that capacity was part of
the individual,
right.
Me as well as everyone else to determine
if there was a mode of acting in the
world that would restrict that
possibility so that it would no longer
manifests itself and so I spent however
many hours,
$45,000
thinking about that and that's not right
because that's how much time I spent
writing about it most of that time
because I have a very obsessive mind in
some sense our lock on a problem.
I can't let it go or can't let me go.
I didn't know which way to think about
it and so it wasn't only that I was
writing for three hours a day.
I was thinking about it all the time.
Right from the time I woke up until the
time I went to sleep and I was reading
about it obsessively.
You know,
I read a tremendous amount when I was in
graduate school and so the reason I'm
telling you all of that is to answer
this question is,
but then I spent 30 years lecturing
about it and you know,
I started out with my lectures fairly
structured because I was still wrestling
with the ideas,
but I tried over the years to reduce the
amount of scaffolding safety wire
netting that was underneath me while I
was lecturing until I got to the point
where I didn't need to do anything other
than sit for 10 minutes and think,
okay,
what's the problem?
Where am I going?
I'm exploring a solution.
I'm not necessarily putting forward a
pre constructed solution like it'll be
in the universe of solutions I've
considered,
but I'd like to get it sharper and
clearer.
So I got to the point where I could go
from the problem through the story using
all these things that I had already
talked about a new and so then I can
sequence them.
And I think the closest analogy I can
think of is jazz improvisation.
It's something like that.
You know,
an expert musician has a tremendous
number of hubs,
habits,
deeply ingrained like an athlete,
same thing that,
that,
that are part and parcel built into to,
to him or her.
And so I have that and so then I can
come out and think,
okay,
well a little of this and little of
that,
and that's new.
It's like each of these ideas is a
personality of sorts and you can let
them have a dialogue in real time and
see where it goes.
And that's the story,
right?
That's what a great author does when he
writes a book,
as he puts out some characters and then
he lets the characters do whatever they
would do and that reveals the story.
And so I kind of do that.
I let the ideas do what they're going to
do and see how they fight and compete
with one another and,
and,
and then that's see what people wanted.
Lectures,
assuming that this is a lecture and it
probably isn't,
it's probably more like a strange sort
of dialogue with the audience.
What people want in a forum like this is
they want to see thought inaction,
right?
They don't want to see something that's
already crystallized and and dad,
which is why I did read the last time I
was here,
although I do that rarely,
they want to see something.
They want to see what they want to see.
Technically speaking is something if you
thought about metaphysically as they
want to see the logos,
inaction.
That's really what people always want to
see and I mean that philosophically and
so the real time part of it,
the fact that it's not a contrived
performances out actually crucial to its
success and also what keeps me engaged.
Like it's.
I don't know how these damn lectures are
going to go when I come out here.
I think,
okay,
victim,
man,
that's a big problem.
Okay,
well we could,
we could address it with this and then
we could use this and I can play those
together and we can see how that goes
and then perhaps I'll be able to draw a
rousing conclusion because it's hard to
bring that to the point at the end,
you know,
successfully to something I've got
better at over the tour,
which is quite fun,
but I never don't know if it's gonna
work.
And so I'm on edge when I come out on
stage,
I think,
oh my God,
I've got a big problem here and I've got
a sorted out in 70 minutes and there's
all these people here.
So,
and,
and that makes it really tense for me in
an exciting way.
It's an exhilarating,
you know,
it's an exhilarating challenge,
but that also makes it alive because I
could easily fail so.
Well.
So that's how it's lots of practice.
And,
and then the final thing is I don't talk
about problems that don't matter to me,
they matter,
this victim thing that matters.
It's important fundamental.
And so every night I come out and I
think,
okay,
well what's the fundamental problem for
tonight?
And it's a problem that affects me as
far as deep down as much as I can go,
you know?
And so yeah.
Do you know the point in life when you
became a serious person?
And I mean,
I mean that in the best sense of it
because when people asked me what it's
like to be on tour with you,
I always say,
well,
he takes life seriously and it's making
me take life more seriously.
And I think it's making these people
take life more seriously.
Do you remember the moment that that
happened?
Yes.
Can you tell me that moment?
Yes,
I can.
Yeah.
So it was in I think 19,
83.
And this is a strange story.
Um,
I came home from a party,
a university party,
and I wasn't in the best mood.
I've always had a certain proclivity
towards depression,
which I've recently discovered is
probably an autoimmune problem in any
case.
Um,
I'd gone to this party and I'd had a lot
to drink because I like to drink.
And um,
I didn't know,
I wasn't happy with something that
happened at the party,
wasn't happy with the way I behave.
I mean,
that's not uncommon,
right?
If you,
if like to drink then you're not happy
with the way he behaved.
Those things just go together.
And so,
but there was,
it was deeper than that.
It wasn't just that I was unhappy with
the way the party had gone,
but I was deeply dissatisfied with how I
was oriented in life.
Like I felt that I felt that there was
a,
it was a nihilism,
I suppose that was,
that was gnawing at me and this was not
long after I'd stopped.
I'd worked for Socialist Party in Canada
for a while when I was a kid.
And this wasn't long after I stopped
doing that.
And so I kind of lost my moorings and
um,
you know,
the Christianity that my mother
practiced in particular,
I had abandon that when I was like 13.
And so I didn't have any structured
orient me at all.
And so I was experimenting a little bit
with artistic production at this point.
Not a lot,
but a bit.
And so I took out this canvas from my,
my closet and I sat down and I sketched
out this picture and I just let my
imagination roam.
And what came out was,
it was a crucifixion and there was a,
I drew a picture of Christ on the,
on the crucifixion,
but with a very judgemental face,
very angry face,
and with a snake wrapped around his
waist.
And it was really harsh picture.
It was like an expressionist picture.
And not that I have the talent of an
expressionist,
but,
but that's what it was.
And I thought,
I mean,
I,
I wasn't thinking,
I didn't think that I was thinking in
religious terms at that point at all.
And you know,
I was an absolutely sporadic church
goer.
And,
and uh,
I was absolutely shocked by this
picture.
I thought,
what,
where the hell did this come from?
What did that possibly me,
you know,
I,
it took me years to figure out what it
meant.
I mean,
really good one,
one thing.
So I'll tell you part of what it meant.
So Carl Jung said something very
interesting about the structure of the
New Testament.
He said that the Gospel,
Christ is fundamentally,
although not entirely fundamentally a
figure of compassion,
but the ideal is not only compassion,
the ideal is also a judge because an
ideal is a judge.
You know,
let's say you have an ideal law,
it's a judge because you don't live up
to it,
and so your ideal is always looking at
you like you're not what you should be.
And the higher the ideal,
the more judgmental the judge.
Well,
that's why he thought the book of
revelation first of all emerged in the
as an unconscious revelation,
which because Christ comes back at the
end of time,
so,
so the story goes as the ultimate judge
and virtually no one is judged
acceptable while why?
Well,
because by the highest possible see
speaking psychologically,
you can biologically for that matter,
the idea of Christ is the instantiation
of the ideal.
As such,
that's what it is.
Now,
it might be more than that,
but that's what it is.
It's,
it's whatever a human being would be.
If a human being was perfect and it's an
effort of our collective imagination to
represent that symbolically,
which we do with cathedrals,
for example,
we paint the image of Christ against the
dome that represents eternity itself.
That's the ideal.
Now you might say,
well,
I don't believe in the ideal.
It's like you're missing the point.
You're missing the point and so so that
ideal is a judge and the farther you are
away from that ideal,
the harsher the judge,
and so the snake was part of that
because the thing is is that if you're
low enough and the ideal is high enough,
the ideal itself is so judgmental and so
detached for you that it starts to look
to you like your enemy.
And so that was the painting and it was
like,
and I was asking a question.
That was the thing that I was asking the
question.
I was asking like what would I have to
do to set this?
What would I have to do to set the
situation that I'm in?
Right?
And so then I drew this picture and the
picture.
How had the had the answer?
I mean,
artistic production always has the
answer.
That's where the answers come from,
you know,
and so that was a manifestation of
imagination.
It was,
it was part of me attempting in its
symbolic mode of personified thinking to
deliver a message.
And so I swore that night that I was
going to do whatever it took to set
myself,
right,
period,
whatever.
And I was dead serious about that.
And so that was the,
that was the moment.
And then I don't know what I did with
that picture.
I,
I hid it in my closet because I was so
freaked out by it.
I thought,
what the Hell is this?
It's like some schizophrenia nightmare.
It's like underneath the covers with
that thing.
But that was the,
that.
And that was,
it wasn't long after that that I wrote
the first essay that eventually turned
into this maps of meaning book.
It was a poem to begin with actually,
that that was how it came about first.
So that's when I decided to be,
to straighten myself out regardless of,
to straighten myself out.
That's what I was going to do.
So,
so I think this is our 13th show in
Europe.
We've got a couple more over the next
couple of days and now it sounds like
we're extending for another 30 or 40
probably in the spring.
I mean this thing has just grown and
grown and grown a.
are you shocked at the amount of people
that live in western societies here in
Norway?
Especially when we were in Sweden a
couple of days ago,
but all the countries that we've been in
that live in free societies yet art
completely afraid to say what they think
is absolutely shocking.
Thank you.
I think the most.
I think what I've been most shocked
about in all of that is what's happened
in the UK with the police starting to
prosecute people for crimes of
offensiveness.
That's just.
And I think that's probably partly
because I'm an.
I mean,
I see that as broadly reflective of,
of something that's happening in the
West in general,
but it's particularly shocking and
appalling to me as a,
as a western know because obviously
counted that was part of the British
empire and when I grew up,
like there was a pretty tight affinity
still in western Canada with the British
empire.
I mean our,
our maps where the dominion of Canada
was still pink,
you know,
it was still part of the British empire.
We Sang God save the Queen Constantly at
public gatherings.
That's gone by the wayside.
And so,
and you know,
I've always regarded British common law
and the British parliamentary tradition
as well.
One of it perhaps the highest
achievement of western civilization.
I mean,
you could argue about that,
but it's,
it's in the top 10,
let's say.
And then to see the Brits who also have
this phenomenal sense of humor,
this ability to say anything,
no matter how outrageous about anyone
and to include themselves in the joke,
right?
Which is such an elegant way of
expressing comedic freedom to see them
going down this road is just,
it just,
it's,
it's what is it exactly.
While it's deeply saddening,
that's for sure.
And,
and
what's horrifying and it's not exactly
the right word.
I don't know what the word for it is
there certainly sorrow that's associated
with a disbelief.
It's also
at,
at watching that happen in what I still
think is the central core of the idea of
individual sovereignty and freedom as
expressed across the western world.
And so,
and then there's similar manifestations
of that everywhere else,
but the police per prosecuting people
for you know,
asking people to turn in their neighbors
if they say something offensive.
And that's happening in the UK.
Yeah.
Literally what we saw that,
that somebody sent me posters,
pictures of posters in the Scottish
subway,
in the metro,
in the tube,
you know,
saying inviting people to inform on
their neighbors for being offensive.
It's like what the hell,
what,
what?
So I knew this was coming because.
Because I knew we brought our first hate
speech laws in Canada back in the 19
eighties.
We were after this character named Ernst
Zandel,
who is a particularly despicable piece
of work,
hard hat wearing right wing antisemitism
Holocaust denier,
you know,
he had it all that guy,
um,
and you know,
it was his shenanigans,
careless malevolent shenanigans that
entice Canadians into producing hate
speech legislation.
I thought,
no,
that's,
that's not good.
It's not good.
You're making a big mistake.
We're going to pay for this.
It's going to unfold over a long time.
Who defines hate
the crucial
issue.
It's not like it's a scientific category
to judgment.
And the answer is those whom you least
want to have the power to define it
because they're the ones that will take
that power to themselves.
And if you think that isn't gonna Affect
what you get to say,
well you've got another thing coming.
So I think it's,
I think it's going to pay for it and
hopefully,
hopefully we'll wake up and push back
before we have to pay too high a price.
We're going to pay for it.
So yeah,
and we're going to deserve to pay for it
too.
He's talking to you
last night,
last night
it was on this British show called
question time,
which is very famous British show and
there was a,
um,
a woman parliamentarian.
They're from Ireland who was pretty
bright.
I liked listening to her,
but I'm the host asked me about this
character named count.
Dang,
Kyla,
I don't know if you know about him.
I'm his girlfriend.
He's a comedian.
Well,
he thinks he's a comedian and.
but you know,
there are lots of Comedians who think
they're comedians that aren't funny and
I'm not saying he's not funny because
other people think that he's a comedian
too.
But he presents himself as a comedian.
Count Danky law.
I mean that's actually a joke,
that name and his girlfriend had a pug
and I liked count danky him because he
hated that pug and I'm not very fond of
pugs.
I think they're hideous little creatures
and,
and you know,
I don't really hate them if a bug comes
along then all pet it and everything,
but
it's just sort of like the,
the,
this little rat like dog with these
bugs.
If you hit it on the back of the head,
the eyes will pop out and so because
they've been so genetically mishandled
and so,
I don't know,
man.
It's just,
you do realize we're putting this on
youtube and you're just done.
You're unleashing a whole new world to
hate to bug people.
I know,
I know.
but whatever,
whatever.
So you can have your plugin,
you can love it.
My Dad had this dog that was so damn
hideous and useless that it was just a
miracle and he loved it to death and so,
and you know,
that's fine,
but.
And there's kind of an ironic attitude
in the dismissal of pugs and Daniella
didn't like his girlfriend's pug and so
he thought he'd play a mean trick or a
mean slash funny trick and teach it to
do a hail Hitler salute.
I actually thought it was quite funny.
It's like I don't,
look,
I don't see that as glorifying Hitler
hits up Pug for God's sake.
It wasn't,
uh,
it wasn't a,
what do you call those Doberman,
you know,
it was a pub.
It's like teaching a rat to do a hail
Hitler salute.
I love that this has come down to the
breed of dogs with you.
These things matter in terms of,
I love the way they're represented,
you know,
and then,
he,
he taught it to,
it's so horrible.
He and I'm gonna be so killed for this.
He taught it to do it's little salute
when he said gas the Jews,
which is not funny,
you know,
except it's horribly funny,
that's the thing.
Well look,
and so yeah,
you laugh.
That's right.
Because you're all horrible and you
know,
and you know perfectly well that it's
horribly funny and you know,
we need,
we need
to be able to be horribly funny because
life is horrible and we.
And we need to be able to find.
We need to be able to allow people the
freedom to find the ability to transcend
that horror with comedy and a mark of a
free society is that con comedians can
be just exactly what the R is,
which there are people who push the edge
of what's acceptable.
If you're a brilliant comedian,
you get right to the edge,
right?
New dance there.
And the audience is thinking,
Sarah Silvermans a good example of that.
You know,
because you can just see her.
She's gone all politically correct
recently,
but when she was in her heyday,
you could just see Sarah,
she's so smart.
You'd see you're sitting there and she'd
think of something just spectacularly
evil and horrible.
And she think,
oh,
and then she say it,
you know,
and everyone would just crack up because
like the darkest part of their soul had
once thought something like that.
And she dared to Audi read 10.
And by honoring it she also
simultaneously transcended it,
you know?
And that's the beauty of comedy and,
and,
and well.
So anyways,
they,
they went after,
Dang Kyla and nailed him legally.
And I thought that's an that's in Great
Britain as well.
And last night,
so they brought this up one on question
time and you know the,
the Irish woman who said she went off on
a talk about how terrible Kristallnacht
wasn't,
what an awful thing Auschwitz and the
Holocaust was.
It's like,
well,
you're not that morally virtuous to
notice that know.
You know what I mean?
It's like.
And it didn't have anything to do with
the topic at hand.
It's like,
yet you wouldn't say that you noticed
that unless you were implying that there
are people around you including this
count.
Dang,
can I.
Who didn't notice that?
Okay.
It had nothing to do with whether he
should have been prosecuted for his
stupid joke.
And then you can say,
well,
you could say it was a stupid joke,
which it certainly was.
You could say that it was a hateful
joke,
which I don't agree with by the way.
But you could say that.
And I think you could.
You could make a credible case for that.
But then to say that because you think
that the Holocaust bad,
he should be criminally prosecuted.
It's like,
nope,
sorry man,
you've crossed the line and there's no
excuse for it.
And so that's part of what's worrisome
about the state of discourse in the free
West.
That same thing,
comedians won't go to university
campuses,
same thing.
You don't get to be funny.
So if you can't be funny than you're not
free,
you know the gesture and the king's
courts,
the only person who gets to tell the
truth.
And if the king is such a tyrant that he
kills his gesture,
then you know that the evil king is in
charge.
And so when we can't tolerate our
comedians,
it's like,
well,
there you go.
They're the canaries in the coal mine as
far as I'm concerned.
Thank you.
My wife that I wouldn't hit any hornets
with any Hornet's nest with sticks for
like a day.
And now I just hit a big hornet's nest
with this.
So sorry Tammy.
She's here somewhere.
Yeah,
give it up for Jordan's wife,
by the way.
She's been on this entire time.
Thank you.
All right,
so let's at David's fault.
Yeah,
let,
let's shift gears a little bit.
What has been the best part
of this adventure of this tour for you
personally?
Oh,
well,
the best part happens all the time.
The best part I think.
I think I told this story tonight
though.
I'm not sure because I talked to a bunch
of journalists today,
so can't remember when I told this
story,
but this guy came up to me last night.
He was kind of a pierced guy,
rough looking guy and uh,
but he's probably in his late twenties,
maybe early thirties.
He said,
uh,
I've,
I've been smoking drug free for nine
months.
And I said,
hey,
good work man.
Because he looked pretty pleased about
that.
I said,
well,
you know,
hopefully that's a lot better.
And he said it's a lot better.
And I said,
well,
good for you for sticking it out and I
hope you can continue it.
And I meant that because I didn't mean
good for you and hope you can stick it
out.
And he knew I meant that because he
wouldn't have bloody well told me that
to begin with,
he didn't think that that was going to
be the response.
And then he said,
I got nine of my mates to do the same
thing.
Yeah.
I thought right on,
man,
that's great.
And then you know,
this.
I was in Birmingham two nights ago and I
walked out of the hotel and this kid
working class kid came up to me,
you know,
just out of the blue.
And he said,
thank you very much for elevating my
vision.
I thought,
hey look,
it's really good thing to be able to go
around the world and to have people stop
you on the street and say things like
that to you.
It's like that's as good as it gets.
You know?
And people are telling me stories like
all the time they come up and they say,
well you've watched this thing.
It happens all the time.
People come up and they tell me some way
that their house was out of order,
you know,
they are hopeless and,
and nihilistic and drinking too much and
watching too much pornography and
procrastinating too much and being not
serious with the relationship and not
getting along with their parents and you
know,
not formulating a vision and not growing
up and,
you know,
there's just endless ways that you can
descend into a kind of,
what would you call it,
a kind of Grungy,
filthy carpet infested hell and,
and so,
and then they say,
look,
I've been watching your lectures and
I've developed a plan for my life and
I've been trying to be more responsible
and I've been really turned to tell the
truth.
And I mended my relationship with my
father and I got married to my
girlfriend and now I have a flat and I
quit doing drugs and I've just tripled
my salary in the last year.
And um,
and I didn't commit suicide like I was
going to six months ago.
I think I have,
I don't know,
out of 150 people that I talked to each
night,
I would say probably over the course of
the lecture series,
there's probably 10 people like that and
night who tell me that and so see,
because I believe what I said tonight,
I believe that the individual is
sovereign and that individual
sovereignty is the cornerstone of
reality itself and it's the cornerstone
of the state and it's the cornerstone of
reality itself.
I truly believe that to be the case,
that every time I hear someone say,
look,
I've got my act together.
I think that's one more weight on.
You know,
if the scales are always tilting towards
good or towards evil,
then every time someone decides to
straighten themselves up,
they put a mate.
They take a major weight off the evil
side and they put it on the good side
and it's not trivial and I believe that
that's what the redemption of the world
depends on.
It's not political.
It happens at the level of the
individual.
Just like the descent into totalitarian
catastrophe occurs when people abandon
their sovereign responsibility,
which I think is the most accurate way
of diagnosing what happened in the 20th
century.
So whenever someone comes up to me and
says,
I was not doing so well,
and here's three ways where I've really
put my life together,
we have a little 15 second party and we
both know why,
and so that's,
that's as good as it gets.
And so that's happening constantly and I
feel generally speaking that these
events are like their celebrations of
that and so interesting to watch.
The media missed this completely.
It's like they don't have the
conceptual.
What would you say?
They don't have the conceptual tools to
understand that something might be
happening that's worthy of note outside
the purely conventional confines of,
of you know that the stultifying and dol
political discourse,
but it doesn't matter.
It might be nice if it didn't happen.
It doesn't fundamentally mattered
because I'm a psychologist.
I decided a long time ago that the
individual was the right level of
analysis and so it's an absolute.
It's,
it's not a pleasure.
It's not the right way of thinking about
it.
What's rule seven?
Do.
What is meaningful?
Note what is expedient.
This is the most deeply meaningful thing
that I can envision doing.
So that's great.
It's great.
It's hard.
Great is hard when something great
happens,
that's hard,
right?
It's not a.
it's not something trivial,
but it's doesn't matter because because
it's great and so every time someone
says to me,
I'm better.
I'm getting along with my father.
I married my girlfriend.
We're going to have a child.
We were going to have children.
Now we're going to have children.
I think that's one more.
So that's great man.
Thank you.
Tell the audience a little bit about
Jordan Peterson having fun.
We did serious Jordan Peterson Peterson
doing for fun.
I stumped him actually.
It's not like I don't.
It's like most of what I've always done
for fun in my life has been to play,
you know,
and so when I had little kids,
I played with them all the time and my
kids are grown up and I play with them
all the time and my daughter is so
playful.
Despite her rather catastrophic life up
to this point,
she's much better,
but is that every single thing she says
when she's not delivering?
Oh,
like,
uh,
when she's not focused on talking to
people about a serious topic,
everything she says is a joke,
you know,
when my son is ridiculously Tz and
playful and so and so,
that's fun.
And when they were little kids,
we just played all the time.
And so I really liked that and most of
the people who've been my close friends
have been people like that.
They're there.
They play with their speech all the
time,
which is why I think I get along with
Comedians,
you know,
it's like,
it's partly why we travel well together.
And John Now my tour manager,
who's a great guy,
very,
very useful.
He's also a comedian and Rogan's a
comedian and so many of the people that
I got along with her comedians and,
and,
and the best interviews on how to beat
with comedians because there's that
element of play.
So I really like that on this tour.
There's not a lot of fun.
I wouldn't say we had a good time when
we went to the comedy club in Salt Lake
City,
Salt Lake City.
That was,
that was fun.
That was 45 minutes of fun and I had
some fun at Cambridge.
I had.
I had some fun in it.
Just to be clear,
I brought Jordan up as the surprise
guest.
I did about our standup and then I
brought Jordan up and we did.
We sort of did stand up together.
We just kind of riff for about 45
minutes and people were.
Yeah,
it was fun.
They were thrilled and they love seeing
you laugh.
I was at the Cambridge Union just a
couple of days ago and I was in a fairly
high spirited mood and I had a fair bit
of fun with the students there.
It was still serious,
but you know what I really like what the
times in my life that I've had the best
time is when I'm sitting around with a
variety of people who are very amusing
and all they're trying to do is to
outwit each other with something absurd
and funny and it was really a part of,
I don't know if it's a part of,
of Scandinavian culture or not,
but in,
in,
in the West where I grew up,
which is a working class culture.
I mean most of what my friends and I did
with regards to conversation was like
half winded up,
up,
up men upmanship.
I guess that's what it is.
Your goal was to say something funnier
than the person just before you said.
And so it was competitive humor and I
really,
really liked that a lot.
And so when I'm able that's great
relief,
but this tour,
like it's very tightly scheduled,
crazily tightly scheduled.
And tammy and I decided at the beginning
that because it was such an absurd
opportunity that it was a working tour,
you know,
and that we were going to subordinate
everything to making sure that these
shows went as well as they possibly
could and that we would take whatever
refuge in amusement we could,
you know,
where we could steal it.
And we've had some of that.
I mean the last time we were in Oslo,
we walked up to the sculpture gardens
and so that was really cool and we
walked down the boulevard and we only
had about an hour and a half to take a
look around the city,
but it was a nice hour and a half,
you know,
the sun was out and we enjoyed
ourselves.
And so that's rule 12,
right?
Pet a cat on the street when,
when you see one,
when you encountered one and you take
your joy where you can get it and you
don't complain if it's not happening
perhaps as often as it should,
especially when you're given like we
have been this absolutely improbable
adventure and we'll have time.
Hopefully God willing,
knock on wood with some luck for some
more fun in the future.
That's actually quite a segue to my next
question,
which is because you about stories so
much in the importance of stories.
Does the Jordan Peterson story had a
happy ending and does that even matter
or what do you think that the ending of
the Jordan Peterson story is?
Alright,
don't have any idea.
Um,
you know,
when I was from the time I was about 20,
I kind of had a sense of what would
happen to me.
I had some sense of it,
but only it really only extended until I
was about my age 50,
something like that.
And I didn't know what would.
I didn't have a vision for after that.
And
See,
I thought when I wrote,
wrote maps of meaning,
I remember telling one of my,
my peers,
I said,
I think everyone will think the way that
I think in this book in 50 years.
And he said,
well that's a pretty grandiose claim.
I guess that that was it.
Something like,
well,
fair enough,
you know,
but,
but by the same token,
I wasn't taking,
I wasn't taking credit for the ideas,
like I was taking some credit for
clarifying them.
The ideas were already there.
They're everywhere.
Those ideas,
but clarifying the miss something and so
I knew that when I was working on in
maps of meaning was at the center of
things in some sense and that manifested
itself in my teaching career because,
well I taught at Harvard for six years
and the course there which was based on
my book was very,
very popular and,
and students regarding to this life
changing in the same thing happened at
the University of Toronto.
And so I knew that that power was in
those ideas,
but I don't see my future very clearly
from here on,
in,
you know,
over the next year I'm going to do more
of what I do it.
I want to return to the exodus to exit
this.
I like doing those biblical lectures.
I thought that was useful and important.
So I want to do that.
But my vision kinds of kind of runs out
in December of 2019 and I don't know
what,
because all of this is so unlikely,
you know,
our thought for the last two years,
every single day I thought,
well this is going to come to an end.
Like this is ridiculous.
This is ridiculous.
It's cad continued but it is continuing.
And so I have no idea how.
How do you predict something like that?
I mean,
for the longest time I thought that as
this wave grew,
the probability that I would end up like
a surfer smashed on the beach was the
highest probability and I still probably
think that that's the highest
probability outcome.
But,
but I'm not as apprehensive about that
now as I was because in some sense,
assuming I don't do anything
spectacularly stupid,
like defend count.
Dang Kyla on Dave Rubin.
Thank you.
Well,
who would like to that?
Who would have liked to have taken me
out,
have thrown the worst that they could
throw at me?
As far as I can tell.
I mean,
my,
my cardinal day in terms of vilification
and it's quite a contest by the way
because there were many days like that
was the day where I was simultaneously
accused by eight an all right magazine
of being a Jewish shill and accused by
a,
a Jewish magazine of being tantamount to
Hitler himself.
I thought,
well,
that pretty much does it.
It's like the Nazis hate me because I'm
a Jewish shill and the,
and well,
this particular Jewish publication,
you know,
compared me to Hitler,
and I thought,
well,
that's it.
There's.
Where else do you go after that?
We're going to call me mom.
It's like,
it still already.
He didn't.
That's just not that much past Hitler.
And so you know,
and so I'm not that concerned that in
the absence of some fatal stupidity on
my part,
which certainly could still happen
because we have that proclivity for
fatal stupidity within all of us.
I'm not too concerned that I'm going to
be taken out by my ideological
opponents,
but by the same token,
this is a pretty unwieldy and
unprecedented situation to be in.
And so I'm,
I'm not under any illusions about its
stability or safety.
So who knows,
man.
Well I'll stick with you as long as
you'll keep me.
So,
so far so good.
All right.
So I promised you guys that I was going
to take what I thought was the best
question from you guys.
And there were,
there were hundreds of them.
I was reading through them during the
lecture,
but I thought this was the best we got
out of Oslo.
Will you move to as low and run for
Prime Minister of Norway?
Thank you.
Well first you probably want someone who
can speak Norwegian.
Um,
and second,
more seriously,
um,
throughout my life I've considered a
political career and certainly when I
was young,
very seriously,
that was my ambition till I was about
18.
But,
um,
yeah,
started when I ran for an executive
position in the Socialist Party in my
home province when I was 14.
And so that was the first large scale
public speech I gave to about 700
people.
Wait,
can everyone pause for one second?
Try to picture 14 year old socialist
Jordan Peterson that,
that's an incredible image to me.
What was that kid like?
Me Kinda,
you know,
I,
I speak to a crowd.
Then speech was very successful.
Um,
I lost the position by 13 votes out of
700,
something like that.
And you know,
I had the audience under.
I had the audience.
No.
So you know,
there's certain things about you that
remained constant.
Hopefully I know more than I did then,
you know,
that's to be devoted hope for.
I've stopped
actively pursuing a political career
when I was 18 and the reason for that
was because I became more interested in
something else,
which is what I was talking about
tonight because it turned out that the
political problems that I was interested
in were,
were deep enough arguably not to be
political because they were really,
for some reason I was very interested in
totalitarianism,
right from the time I was like an
adolescent.
I don't know why exactly who the hell
knows why you get interested in what
your interests in some problem.
You know,
this is a thing that's useful to know
about life,
you know,
all of you have problems that bothering
you and you think,
well,
I don't want it to have a problem and
fair enough,
but like there's a whole lot of problems
you could have that could bother you
because there's lots of things wrong
with the world and you can be obsessed
by like a million problems,
right?
Because there's just problems
everywhere,
but you're not some problems grab you.
Why?
It's a mystery history of the autonomy
of being in some sense,
problem grabs you and it will let you
go.
It's like that's suffering in that,
but that's your problem and you know in
that problem might be your destiny.
I think that's right,
is in the problems that grip you are the
portal to your destiny and and so.
Well then you can accept them.
It's like,
what are you going to have?
No problems could good luck with that.
So you've got your problems.
One of the things you learn as a
therapist,
as you don't interfere with people's
problems,
and what I mean by that is this.
Let's say you come to me and we have a
discussion about what's going wrong in
your life,
and I listened because I want you to
explain what the problems are because
what do I know about your life?
It's like I need to listen so that I can
hear what your problem is and not rush
to a conclusion and then I want to
listen while you generate a solution.
Now I'm going to help by asking
questions and help you explore it,
but if I.
let's say you lay out your problem and I
think,
hey,
I know what would fix that,
and then I just say to you,
well,
you know,
here's the solution.
Well first of all,
you're going to be very annoyed about
that because I just took your problem
and it was up to you to wrestle with
that problem and come up with a solution
and then to have a little self
congratulatory burst of pleasure at your
own intuitive genius that you could
solve your problem and then then you're
motivated because you've come up with a
solution.
Maybe you go implement it right and so
well.
So my problem became something that
wasn't political and so I pursued that
and so I'm not going to pursue a
political career and I've also decided
to.
I didn't know this,
but I don't have the temperament for it.
I couldn't do it.
I find the adversarial interviews that
I'm in,
for example,
they take me like it takes me three days
to recover from one of those,
what it does because I don't like that
motive discourse.
And if your political,
you're in that mode of discourse all the
time and I'm not cut out for it.
I got not a particularly combative
person by nature.
I'm a person who's terrified about
leaving monsters under the rug
ignored,
but that is not the same thing.
And it's not like I enjoy the process of
calling them out and hashing them
through,
but I think well better get out them
while they're small.
So,
so,
so no,
I'm not coming to Norway.
That's the answer to that question.
All right,
well on that note,
I've said this to you privately before,
but I may as well say publicly since
we're putting this up on the youtube,
this what we're doing here,
this started as a professional joy for
me,
but it has become a personal joy that I
can't explain.
I am better than when we started.
Like I know what it's like to be these
people that taking these ideas in and
changing and uh,
and I'm better and it's.
And it's because of the work that you've
put into your life that you've helped
give to all of us.
So,
uh,
I want to thank you for that.
And on that note,
I've never ended a show like this
before,
but I'm going to get out of the way and
I need you guys to go bananas for Dr
Jordan Peterson.
Thank you guys.
Thanks amy.